antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier or et merci d'être fidèle
au journal d'antenne 2 à la une ce soir
fin de la mutinerie à la centrale de
saint maur près de châteauroux
le chef du gign qui est ce soir notre
invité vous dira que le pire a été évité
cette nuit grâce au sang froid de tous
ceux qui étaient au coeur de cette
affaire
oh
pas de solution miracle à l'issue des
états généraux de la sécurité sociale
les divergences restent nombreuses
en direct les premiers commentaires de
philippe seguin dans les turbulences
monétaires la france et l'allemagne
serre les rangs au sommet paris et bonn
décide de la création d'un comité
économique et financier un an dans
l'insolence et la dérision de thierry le
luron antenne de lui rend hommage de
m'asseoir dans champs elysées son ami
michel drucker est invitée du journal
détention pour marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
la fin d'une mutinerie à sa mort dans la
banlieue de châteauroux je vous le
disais tout à l'heure le pire a été
évité tout est rentré dans l'ordre ce
matin par une reddition sans condition
des mutins à l'heure des bilans il
semble bien que la rébellion se soit
déclenchée d'une manière quasi spontanée
reste les dégâts matériels ils sont
considérables
gérard beaufils vision de désolation
dans cette région modèle 12 ans base
dont il ne reste aujourd'hui presque
rien
le déchaînement de violences de la nuit
dernière tout ce qui pouvait être cassé
là était ici par exemple il y avait un
atelier 1 hectare maintenant
complètement ravagé déjà les dégâts
peuvent être estimés à 100 millions de
francs
le feu le pliage le saccage systématique
les mutins ont démontré leur volonté de
détruire cette flambée soudaine était
elle prévisible
eh bien il semble que oui plusieurs
incidents graves s'était déjà déroulée
récemment commencé parce que les détenus
supporte mal
les longues peines on supporte mal
6-13 ans particulièrement répressive oui
vous la dire par là qu au niveau en
particulier des réductions de peine
supplémentaire pour gager que cette
jeune elle de réinsertion sociale la
commission d'application des peines n'a
pas effectivement la vision de la tribu
est systématiquement trois mois les
autorités ont choisi la fermeté pour
mater la révolte de la centrale de
saint-maur
dès le milieu de la nuit des renforts de
gendarmes et des crs arrivés de poitiers
et de bordeaux ont investi les abords de
la prison pour prévenir d'éventuelles
tentatives d'évasion le préfet avait
même signifié qu'il ferait tirer sur les
détenus qui tenteraient de s'échapper
tout au long de la nuit les forces de
l'ordre ont appréhendé des prisonniers
au fur et à mesure de leur progression
dans l'établissement et aux petits jours
avant l'assaut final
la plupart des détenus d'ailleurs
s'était rendu spontanément du blessé
wada
c'est beaucoup de dégâts dresse un plus
bas à l'inventaire est en cours les
rééditions se conduisent les opérations
de contrôle également
aujourd'hui les prisonniers sont à
reloger la prison entièrement à
reconstruire on assurait jusqu'à présent
qu'elle présentait les conditions
maximum de sécurité
capitaine legorjus bonsoir vous êtes le
patron du gign je remercie d'être là
parce que ça fait quarante huit heures
pratiquement que vous n'avez pas dormi
et que vous êtes sur cette affaire
est-ce que vous avez eue sincèrement
l'impression qu'à un moment ou un autre
tout pouvait basculer cette nuit est
tout à fait on a eu cette impression dès
le départ dès notre arrivée plus tôt sur
les lieux vers 19h30 et à plusieurs
reprises au cours de la nuit on a eu le
sentiment effectivement que tout pouvait
arriver aux otages il faut faire preuve
d'une force de conviction extraordinaire
quand on se retrouve face à des gens
tels que ceux qui étaient en face de
vous je crois qu'il faut surtout faire
preuve de calme et c'est ce calme ainsi
que celui de toutes les autorités
présentes qui a permis entre autres
d'arriver à une solution satisfaisante
car sans entrer dans le détail comment
avez-vous procédé la nuit dernière est
la première chose qu'il a fallu faire
c'est établir le contact avec les gens
qui nous étaient opposés et on a eu la
chance de pouvoir avoir un échange avec
un certain nombre d'entre eux plus
responsables que d'autres et qui au
début difficilement et au fur et à
mesure du déroulement de la nuit plus
facilement elle nous ont conduit à
imaginer une solution positive précision
quand vous dites chance vous avez
retrouvé des prisonniers que vous
connaissiez que vous aviez arrêté ou que
vous aviez côtoyé à d'autres certains
d'entre vous et comment ça s'est passé
on dit que ces prisonniers étaient des
prisonniers politiques expliqué mois
certains d'entre eux étaient politiques
mais il était accompagné d'autres
catégories de détenus leurs
caractéristiques c'était encore une fois
leur prise de responsabilités la prise
de conscience qu'ils avaient qu'il
n'était pas nécessaire de toucher aux
agents pénitentiaires qui étaient
détenus en otages étaient presque une
négociation vous avez mené le mil le
garde des sceaux n'aime pas ce terme de
négociations qu'est ce que vous leur
avez donné en contrepartie on leur avait
promis quelque chose c'était pas une
négociation je crois qu'avant tout
c'était un dialogue avec eux lorsque
vous êtes dans une situation difficile
comme celle là il faut créer un climat
de confiance et sans calcul
il faut chercher à créer ce climat de
confiance alors qu'au cours de
des discussions on amène quelque chose
de positif c'est normal mais nous
n'avons jamais négocié avec eux
véritablement certains n'ont pas cherché
à faire dégénérer la situation
pas ceux qui discutent avec nous mais il
faut savoir qu avait des clans à
l'intérieur de cette prison et à
plusieurs reprises ce qui protégeait les
otages ont dû subir les assauts
physiques de certains de leurs collègues
georges ibrahim abdallah est incarcéré à
sa mort est ce qu'il est intervenu
personnellement dans cette affaire il
était incarcéré à sa mort il n'a pas
participé à notre connaissance aucune de
ses actions mais c'est vrai qu'il est
rentré lui même dans sa cellule après
avoir été libéré par certains mutins on
lui a ouvert sa cellule il a circulé
librement mais la plupart du temps il
est demeuré dans sa cellule ce genre de
situation ça ment ou dans une autre
centrale vous l'aviez envisagée au gign
ou pas tout à fait le gêne depuis 1973 a
eu à connaître à peu près une dizaine de
mutinerie c'est sans doute la plus grave
car douze otages détenus à les
conditions si difficiles c'est quelque
chose que nous n'avons encore vu
merci après les faits la réflexion la
centrale de saint maur est un
établissement modèle conçu pour recevoir
440 détenus au moment de la mutinerie
ils n'étaient que 427 à l'intérieur de
l'établissement
première conclusion il n'y avait donc
pas de problème de surpopulation
à sa mort le problème c'est plutôt celui
des conditions de vie au quotidien
plusieurs détenus qui purgent de très
longues peines n'avait pas hésité à
alerter la chancellerie sur leurs
conditions de détention et sur
l'application des peines
thierry calmette la centrale de
saint-maur 450 cellule un détenu par
cellule
8000 m² d'ateliers
mais près d'un quart des prisonniers
sont des condamnés à perpétuité la
catégorie d sans espoir que connaissent
bien les visiteurs de prison
écoutez à sa mort je crois qu'on a sorti
la semaine dernière où il ya quinze
jours je ne sais plus un détenu qui
avait fait 36 ans de prison il y a
actuellement des plus qui à ma
connaissance à plus de 45 ans de prison
pour différents délits bien sûr c'est le
problème de la langue solitude du détenu
dans sa cellule
la longue nuit du détenu qui en fait se
pose la question de savoir ce qui fera
quand il sortira de sa détention et il
aura payé sa peine
est ce que la société va va l'accueillir
est ce qu'il va pouvoir le trouver du
travail
les nouvelles prisons qui vont être
construites
sur proposition du ministère la justice
vont faciliter le travail je présume
évidemment c'est une bonne chose dans la
mesure où ça va permettre un certain
nombre de maisons d'arrêt de faire de la
place mais ce que nous craignons nous
c'est que les cinquante mille détenus
actuellement dans les prisons deviennent
rapidement 60me 70000 épi pourquoi pas
plus ça c'est un premier point le
deuxième point c'est que la plupart des
ces établissements sont dans des régions
totalement excentré qui sont dans le fin
fond de la bourgogne ou de certains
départements où il sera pratiquement
impossible de trouver les 40 visiteurs
de prison qu'il est souhaitable d'avoir
par établissement interrogé ce matin par
nos confrères de la fp le garde des
sceaux monsieur allemand chalandon a
notamment déclaré je cite ces propos les
détenus de sa mort ne sont pas victimes
d'une inégalité de traitement j'ai même
l'impression qu'ils sont
particulièrement favorisés par rapport à
ceux qui séjournent dans des maisons
d'arrêt traditionnels voilà ce que l'on
pouvait dire ce soir sur cette affaire
une autre information qui concerne la
justice le conseil d'état vient de
donner un avis favorable à la réforme de
l'instruction avis favorable avec
quelques réserves tout de même le projet
consiste je vous le rappelle à dessaisir
le magistrat instructeur de la décision
de mise en détention d'un inculpé au
profit d'une chambre de trois magistrats
dont aucun les juges d'instruction à
paris
suite et fin des états généraux de la
sécurité sociale aujourd'hui on a
surtout parlé du problème de la retraite
et de son financement
une fois n'est pas coutume la cgt le
cnpf sont tombés d'accord sur la
nécessité de maintenir jusqu'à 60 ans
les salariés dans l'entreprise afin de
régler le problème du financement des
retraites
véronique auger les états généraux se
sont terminées en grande pompe
l'organisateur a bien mis les points sur
les i qu'on ne vienne plus dire au
gouvernement qu'il faut une concertation
nationale sur la sécurité sociale que
les partis politiques n'inscrive plus
l'ouverture d'un grenelle de la sécu
dans leur programme
c'est fait en réalité les résultats de
ces 20 heures de débats sont bien
maigres
difficile en effet de faire rentrer la
baleine de la sécurité sociale dans un
bocal
comme l'a dit l'un des animateurs jean
boissonnat chacun des 80 intervenants
étaient venus avec son discours
sauf exception hier ils n'en sont pas
sortis seul avantage de ces discussions
souvent mortellement ennuyeuse tous ont
été obligés d'écouter le point de vue
des autres on a même assisté à un début
de convergence entre le cnpf et la cgt
tous les deux ont trouvé paradoxal le
fait qu'on veuille reculer l'âge de la
retraite au moment où les entreprises
abuser des pré retraite à 55 ans pour
supprimer des emplois
sinon aucune solution de compromis n'a
été trouvé sur un nouveau mode de
financement de la sécurité sociale
seul suggestions retenues par les
journalistes animateurs la hausse des
taxes sur les tabacs et alcools et
l'instauration d'un taux unique de
remboursement pour tous les vrais
médicaments
une fois de plus de la balle est dans le
camp du gouvernement avant de me tourner
en direct vers cilip ce lien pour voir
quelles sont les suites que le
gouvernement souhaite donner aux états
généraux nous allons essayer de vous
montrer que tous les pays du monde sont
confrontées au problème de la protection
sociale
prenons l'exemple du japon c'est le pays
industriels qui a le plus fort taux de
croissance on peut même dire que les
japonais sont les financiers entre
guillemets de la planète et pourtant
comme les autres ils ont du mal à s'en
sortir
reportage de patrick boitet et pascal
couillaud les époux matthew bara à 70
ans passés vivent bien dans la banlieue
de tokyo
le repas leur livrer deux fois par jour
ils ont une aide ménagère régulière et
les soins leur sont prodigués à domicile
seulement les matsubara honte
hypothéquer leur maison auprès de la
municipalité
pour bénéficier de ces services chaque
prestation est payante
en six ans ils ont déjà dépensé le tiers
des 2 millions de francs de l'hypothèque
mais il préfère cela à la maison de
retraite inconvénient principal de cette
expérience pilote ceux qui ne possèdent
rien n'ont droit à rien la ville devrait
pouvoir fournir gratuitement des
services aux gens qui ne peuvent pas
payer
alors bien sûr on y réfléchit mais ça
n'existe pas encore
l'expérience de musashino symbolise bien
le problème de la protection sociale au
japon où plus que dans les autres pays
développés les vieillards et les plus
démunis sont dans une situation délicate
d'abord à cause des lacunes du système
national de retraite
ils datent de 1960 dans la plupart des
cas au terme de leur vie les japonais ne
peuvent compter sur une allocation
mensuelle suffisante
ils doivent rentrer dans un avis public
ou chercher un nouvel emploi il n'est
pas rare de voir des hommes de plus de
70 ans exerçait encore une activité
je veux confirmer car je suis en bonne
santé
tant que je pourrai faire deuxième
problème du japon une infrastructure
hospitalière insuffisante
le pays possède bien des établissement
ultramoderne et bon marché mais la place
y manquent les hôpitaux publics sont
obligés de refuser du monde
les gens aimeraient bien venir dans les
hôpitaux publics
mais il y en a peu on est obligé de les
envoyer dans le privé le privé
représentent les deux tiers des places
disponibles la qualité des soins
dispensés dépend du standing de
l'établissement dans les cliniques bon
marché le personnellement et les proches
sont invités à venir eux-mêmes s'occuper
des patients aujourd'hui le gouvernement
japonais affirme essayer de réduire ces
inégalités devant la maladie et la
vieillesse
il y a urgence la population japonaise
sera la plus vieille du monde en l'an
2000 les sionistes en temps on regarde
ce qui se passe au nord japon et patrick
boîte et on se dit que la sécu dans le
fond c'est pas mal non c'est pas mal et
si certains ne sont pas encore persuadés
que la france possède un des meilleurs
pour ne pas dire le meilleur système de
sécurité sociale augmente et j'espère
convaincu pour revenir aux états
généraux qui nous concerne je suis navré
qu'il vous est ennuyé et de rajouter
deux ou trois minutes ce camp du oui
alors je voudrais vous demander moi si
vous les avez regardés
je n'y étais pas et hier vous étiez je
crois que non que n'aurait-on dit que
n'aurait-on dit s'il y avait était on
aurait dit que le gouvernement cherchait
à peser sur la réflexion et le débat
les partenaires sociaux n'ont le parti a
été pris de laisser débattre en toute
liberté
nous tirerons les conclusions de leurs
débats après coup il ne fallait pas
mélanger les genres
est ce que vous trouvez qu'on a fait
avancer les choses oui moi je vous
trouve beaucoup moins je vous trouve
beaucoup trop méchant pour résultat des
états généraux d'abord le simple fait
qu'ils disent qu'ils se soient déroulés
est un événement ces deux journées ne
sont jamais que la consécration d'un
événement 'utility' prend ses racines
mais déjà plusieurs semaines puisqu'il y
a eu des des réunions de ce genre dans
tous les départements quarante mille
personnes y ont participé
le comité des sages a fait rapport de
synthèse j'ai moi même et d'autres
ministres sur lui quelques dizaines
d'organisations sans une organisation
qui était reçu par les stages il ya ces
deux journées de travail
je crois très sincèrement peu sur un
sujet de société
on a vu à l'occasion des états généraux
comme on avait vu à l'occasion des
réflexions sur le code de la nationalité
émerger une nouvelle forme d'exercice de
la démocratie
alors il ya quand même j'ai quand même
remarqué deux trois choses qui sont
sortis de ceux de certains généraux
par exemple il ya une sorte de consensus
sur l'augmentation des taxes sur les
tabacs et alcools à condition que ces
gains aille à la sécurité sociale
alors vous est ce que vous seriez
d'accord pour augmenter les taxes sur le
tabac l'alcool serait d'accord par
exemple augmenter la taxe sur le tabac
s'il ya bruxelles de nous interdisait
pas puisqu'un gouvernement précédent
avait essayé il s'était fait sanctionner
non ce qui peut effectivement être
envisagée à la suite des états généraux
c'est une augmentation du prix du tabac
dont le produit serait affecté à la
sécurité sociale il ya un autre
consensus joue quasi consensus qui s'est
produit sur la nécessité d'une recette
supplémentaire d'un prélèvement général
pour l'ensemble de la sécurité sociale
et plus particulièrement pour la
vieillesse
car il faut bien savoir qu'en matière de
vieillesse on revient aux problèmes qui
étaient évoquées par le film même si
nous décidions en 1988 de ne pas payer
de retraite aux gens qui partent en
retraite
ils sont quatre à cinq cent mille même
s'ils ont décidé que tous les gens qui
travaillent dans les caisses de retraite
caisse nationale caisses régionales lui
ont décidé qu'ils vont aller travailler
gratuitement
je dis ça pour ceux qui disent qu'à des
frais de gestion excessifs même si on
faisait tous ça nous serions quand même
en déficit à la fin 88 c'est dire que
toutes mesures structurelles en matière
de vieillesse ne peut avoir des effets
que dans 15 20 ou 30 ans c'est dire que
dans l'immédiat il faut une recette tout
le monde l'a reconnue bien c'est un
point très positif daniel aussi d'aller
à dire vers cette recette supplémentaire
parce que vit avec les impôts aussi bien
écouter cette hausse est au gouvernement
maintenant d'apprécier je vais lui faire
des propositions sur le base de tout ce
qui a été dit le premier ministre
appréciera nous prendrons selon toute
vraisemblance des mesures immédiates
d'ici au 15 janvier
d'ici au 1er janvier le premier de
savoir lesquels et d'autre part pour
certaines autres mesures qui valent
davantage pour le moyen et le long terme
eh bien nous demanderons au conseil
économique et social d'affiner encore
les propositions de manière à ce que le
prochain gouvernement soit prêt à
légiférer pour les années 2000 et 2000
une dernière question est témoin d'un
doute monsieur le ministre on dit que le
gouvernement est divisé sur le problème
de la sécurité sociale il ya des gens
qui veulent des mesures énergiques comme
vous tient à l'autre qui freine en
disant pas de vagues avant les
présidentielles soient exagérées là
c'est chose qui est certain c'est qu'à
l'intérieur d'un gouvernement comme de
toute collectivité humaine il y a des
discussions avant qu'on prenne une
décision
il ya des points de vue différents le
premier ministre les arbitres et une
fois que pour le ministre a décidé et
bien tous ceux qui sont aux
gouvernements suivent la décision du
premier ministre
merci à karlsruhe en allemagne fin du
sommet franco-allemand c'était le 50e un
sommet qui confirme que l'entente entre
les deux pays demeurent le moteur de
l'union européenne le fait nouveau
aujourd'hui c'est la création d'un
comité économique et financier
franco-allemand philippe gassot cible de
ce 50e sommet franco-allemand on
retiendra la volonté des deux pays de
constituer une force économique et
financière pour affronter ensemble les
turbulences mondiales
jacques chirac et françois mitterrand
qui revendiquait chacun la paternité de
l'idée d'un conseil économique et
financier ont mis fin à une sourde
querelle de communiquer pour reconnaître
que la naissance d'un tel organisme
était devenue capitale
monsieur le premier ministre français et
moi même nous en avions discuté au cours
des jours précédents et lui comme moi
pensaient que c'était une donnée
importante de ce qu'il convenait de
faire à karlsruhe
il faut absolument renforcer les
systèmes qui existent déjà le cas
échéant créé d'autres particuliers faut
absolument préserver et j'ajoute
renforcer le système monétaire européen
ce comité économique et financier
franco-allemand sera créée le 22 janvier
date anniversaire de la signature du
traité de l'elysée mais pour les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement la prochaine
échéance est le 4 décembre avec le
sommet européen de copenhague
voyons rapidement les autres faits
marquants de l'actualité ensuite pleins
feux sur la navette américaine une
navette qui va peut-être connaître une
nouvelle jeunesse grâce à tout à l'heure
retour à paris de dominique servait
médecins membres du secours populaire
elle avait disparu et au salvador
pendant deux jours avant d'être
retrouvée la semaine dernière le docteur
servait expliqué qu'elle s'était caché
dans la montagne après une attaque de
l'armée régulière entre des rebelles
promotion de rudolph noureev après 26
ans de silence france il vient d'obtenir
un visa pour l'union soviétique
l'objectif de son voyage rendre visite à
sa mère malade
le soutien américain à la résistance
afghane sera renforcé les dirigeants du
jaï dean on visite à la maison blanche
ronald reagan appelle au retrait des
troupes soviétiques d'afghanistan
résolution vient d'être adoptée en ce
sens par les nations unies le président
du parlement iranien selon gianni
appelle à la mobilisation générale lors
de la prière ce matin à téhéran
il a annoncé deux nouvelles opérations
dans le golfe l'iran attaquera sur tous
les fronts contre l'irak et
éventuellement les états unis
aux etats unis plus d'un an après
l'accident le challenger les
spécialistes de la nasa tente de mettre
au point un procédé qui permettrait
l'évacuation de la navette en cas de
catastrophe le système est testé depuis
quelques mois témoins ces images
commentées par pascal vanier la nasa
catapulte ses astronautes du haut des
montagnes de l'utah sauver les équipages
demeure la préoccupation majeure après
l'accident de challenger grandeur nature
le premier système envisagé
les astronautes sont éjectés à l'aide
d'une petite fusée après avoir fait
sauter le sas d'accès l'astronaute salon
chouine glissière un autre membre
d'équipage attache la fusée au
scaphandre il s'agit d'éviter l'aise de
la navette deuxième système testé à
houston l'astronaute glisse le long
d'une perche télescopique
il a déjà bouclé son parachute ces deux
procédés ne sont utilisables qu après
les deux premières minutes de vol
ils auraient donc pu servir lors de
l'accident de challenger les américains
semblent convaincus par les deux
systèmes
mais leur choix n'est pas fait
observateur intéressé les européens pour
la sécurité à bord d'hermès il s'oriente
vers un module éjectable tiercé demain
sur l'hippodrome de saint-cloud voici
tout de suite les pronostics de
pierrette brès ils sont 23 au départ
qu'ils arrêtent a choisi le 16 le 5 et
le 13 le 3 le 10 le 11 le 18 et le neuf
je répète le 16 le 5 le 13 est le 3 le
10 le 11 le 18 et le neuf
voilà j'avais un résultat de tennis à
vous donner je vous signale tout
simplement que henri leconte notre
rythme nationale s'est qualifiée pour
les demies
finale du tournoi de wembley il jouera
contre lendl ça c'est un coup dur
football coup dur pour les hollandais
précisément vous souvenez sans doute de
ces images incident bombes fumigènes sur
un gardien de but ce soir là les pays
bas avaient écrasé l'équipe de chypre
8 but à 0 la fédération européenne n'a
pas apprécié du tout moralité les
hollandais ont perdu le match sur tapis
vert 3-0 porte au stade de rotterdam
il est suspendu jusqu'au 31 juillet 90
bilan la hollande devra maintenant
obtenir un match nul en grèce pour se
qualifier en coupe d'europe c'est loin
d'être évident à propos de football je
vous signale que michel drucker qui est
ce soir notre invité vient d'écrire un
livre le numéro un du football les
numéros un du football avec en vedette
copa pelé platini maradona
en deux mots michel qui est là est celui
que vous préférez ah j'avais un faible
pour pelé mais mais je regrette que
platini ne joue plus et on y reviendra
par un je pense quoi c'est dommage c'est
dommage je partage votre avis un
événement demain sur antenne 2 pour la
première fois les téléspectateurs
pourront assister aux meilleurs moments
du dernier spectacle de thierry le luron
300 invités réunis par michel drucker
applaudiront l'artiste comme s'il était
là comme eux asseyons-nous quelques
instants dans la salle du gymnase
un regard invoqua il a déjà un peu
entamé bien tassés je laisse un enfant
pas trop je vais interviewer françois
mitterrand tout à l'heure je vais pas
arriver complètement et aux cons truire
mieux vous vous perdiez tout de suite le
champ des réalités j'ai les jouby's et
puis juge aussi un petit tube je me
présente je m'appelle glandus mon
premier prénom c'est adolphe mon
deuxième prénom c'est benito comme le
démocrate italien citroën c'est
merveilleux surtout pour le débrayage sa
débrayent haut à aulnay c'est fou ils
ont les cadences infernales ils font les
trois huit 8 heures d'arrêt de travail
huit heures de grève huit heures de
prières c'est très dur il faut se poser
est pourquoi le fait parce qu'alex à vos
souhaits
je retrouve mes plantations savez ici et
maintenant j'ai planté
pensez vous qu'ils avaient tous plantés
tous plantés depuis quatre ans j'ai tout
plaqué gb énormément pour cela je vais
pêcher par penser par action voit pas
par ambition
tout est de ma faute
gg déchet énorme et vous êtes bêcheur
près des chefs de wiener aussi j'aurais
pu deviner plusieurs fois par mais ce
n'est pas évident d'accueillir des
personnalités de la trempe de le luron
dans champs elysées par exemple bas ça
va quoi était évident je crois que l'une
des dernières apparitions
on a des souvenirs avec thierry
formidable avec coluche aussi vous savez
quand vous avez sur un plateau de
télévision en direct des gens comme
thierry comme coluche comme de dos on
peut dire vous avez une grenade
dégoupillée
vous savez qu'elle va exploser vous
savez pas quand alors avec thiré exposé
toujours et jamais quand je l'attendais
vous n'avez pas l'impression que
quelquefois il en faisait un peu trop
dans 6 mai tous les humoristes les
caricaturistes en font trop il avait
cette insolence et espièglerie spirit
est un surdoué
je peux pas croire ça fait un an jour
pour jour puisqu'il nous a quittés le 13
novembre d'année dernière je peux pas
croire qu'il est pas là parce que quand
j'envoie cet extrait il est présent
toujours vous imaginez ce qu'il aurait
pu faire thierry avec ce qui se passe
actuellement politique il sera en pleine
campagne électorale
encore un électorat vie il aurait fait
lui les coluche de bonnes affaires avec
les affaires il improvisait beaucoup
alors il avait travaillé beaucoup avec
ton calme avis sur ce dernier spectacle
gymnastes vous verrez demain presque
intégralement et c'est un scoop qui n'a
jamais été diffusé et puis il était
capable quand je prendrai les spectacles
en province avec lui il improvisait
pendant 20 minutes et et il suivait
l'actualité vous savez que henry que
lorsqu'il travaillait à la radio elle a
fait beaucoup de radios il faisait notre
métier il allait il allait voir les
dépêches au desk
c'est un vrai journaliste thierry un
fils avec qui étaient dans la salle
quand il était en province il ya des
personnalités au premier rang il savait
il fallait faire un job d'ingénieur ce
la moindre élection partielle à moins
qu'à élections municipales et
législatives rien alors c'est demain
20h30 demain à 20h30 le luron et les
autres vous les retrouvez d'ailleurs
dans michel drucker michel drucker hors
antenne c'est le fruit d'une
conversation avec notre confrère maurice
à charte merci michel d'avoir répondu à
nos questions
très vite on enchaîne avec la météo
sophie ça se présente bien loin
john ou pas eh bien oui on rit nous
connaîtrons à léger répit demain à
l'évent se calmer ils reprendront de
plus belle dimanche et puis surtout la
motor va se rafraîchir rafraîchir tout
simplement parce que nous sans nous
changeons de régime façon dans un régime
dehors nord ouest les perturbations vont
défiler donc du nord au sud et
rafraîchir l'atmosphère résultats sur la
carte du temps prévu pour demain
seule région épargnée par le mauvais
temps le littoral méditerranéen où le
ciel sera bien dégagé par du mistral
partout ailleurs alternance d'averses et
d'éclaircies et de neige même de la
neige qui tombera sur le relief
et puis une perturbation plus active
abordera la bretagne en fin de journée
les températures sont fraîches
s'échelonnent des 8 degrés à lille
jusqu'à 11° à limoges et de 8° à limoges
donc jusqu'à 18 degrés en corse voilà
henry demain nous serons le samedi 14
novembre et nous perdrons trône ni de
soleil
ce sera la sainte si loin si loin que
c'est pas prochain rendez vous
d'information 23 heures avec au brier de
l'air pendant le week-end vous
retrouverez daniel bilalian et philippe
gassot à 13h15 demain n'oubliez pas
l'assiette anglaise présenté par bernard
rapp à lundi et bon week-end sur antenne
2 n'oubliez pas champs elysées demain
soir bonsoir